how do you weed through the noise this
is something that so many people ask me
because a lot of people come to realize
that i
am answering you know 500 to a thousand
emails a day sometimes and i get
very backed up and so
one of the big questions a lot of people
asked me when i asked the q and a thing
for garyvaynerdrick.com the other day is
gary how do you weed through the noise i
mean how do you go through all those
emails
tweets facebook pounce myspace
everything else how do you find the
stuff that's relevant
important while getting through the
stuff that's not as important and it's
very simple my friends
i'm gonna break it down to you real hard
and raw
everything is important way too many
people don't realize
how one person even though they have two
friends and they're in the middle of
idaho
um are very important people because
word of mouth
for any business was always the most
powerful tool
even back in the day with wine library
before internet before 1997 when we
launched winelibrary.com not bad pretty
early right
before we launched that
word of mouth was the king of building a
business a restaurant
a a anything a movie at times sure
there's media but
word of mouth is powerful little miss
sunshine was on some word of mouth stuff
word of mouth is now on 2.0 3.0
steroids barry bonds roger clemens
whatever you want to call it
word of mouth now is insanity everybody
can email out
pounce out twitter out facebook wallet
a person now can reach so many more
people times
every person word of mouth is on some
crazy shiz now and so to me i'm not
gonna
judge somebody's email to me about
chicken that night
compared to somebody who's telling me
they want to write a blog post about me
or talk about me or make a biz dev deal
with me
every single person that has taken the
time to email you is important
and that's why how do i weed throughout
the noise how do i weed through the
noise
i don't all the noise is positive to me
every piece of it
is important and i highly recommend you
think about it because i think you'll be
shocked
when you least expect it the one that
you would have deleted
not answered the noise turns out to be a
tipping point
have a great day stay well